et l on a du mal à imaginer ici ça a dû
beaucoup changer au maroc je suis votre
boisé sainte catherine et saint florent
2b les endroits où il fallait oui et
c'est toi et tes billes et ouais ouais
ben ali
ping à partir de quel moment ça a changé
ce n'est plus devenu aussi fun drapeaux
jaunes étaient nos costumes
et elle nous a parlé de rock'n'roll et
justement c'est l'époque on apprend
tu vois on s'attarde en demande le
soleil tapait d'en face évidemment on
teste les mondes arabe et en enlever nos
t-shirts
non si l'on sait falil moelleux montréal
vraiment faire 200 c les années 60 70 80
90 ça devient la mondialisation les gros
bang
c'était une époque qui est animée avec
une grande liberté
le monde n est pas tout évidemment nous
ont donné des lits king du score russe
et le wild et on a des biens vont cacher
sur parce que la police pensait mais
c'était moins répressive qu'aujourd'hui
alors là on tripait g dès samedi ils ont
sonné dans à l'ombre
interne en chirurgie et là ça continue
et le paraguay puis la com se dit quand
arrivait 7,8 en vélo on descend d ici où
on va dépendre d'après la surmontait
puis c'était des beaux esprits qu'elle
bournot saint-denis faire un tour sur
sanguine et aux combattants monte à
minuit à kazan où c'est que des
souvenirs de lieux qui ont existé qui
n'existe donc c'est sûr de sa maman ça
me fait de la peine
je cherche le montréal cool maintenant
je vois les anciens en fait avant
c'était beaucoup plus concentrés
maintenant c'est un peu partout
whittington saint-henri my life villeray
vous posez la question vous allez avoir
tellement de réponse et vous partez
assurément des débats votre montréal
coup n'est pas pour montréal cool ni
celui de votre voisin ni même celui du
touriste et c'est la prochaine capsule
comment montréal se vend à
l'international
ça